most of the women on this vote don't
know each other but they're about to go
to sea together ending the next 30 days
sailing around the UK I'll be on board
to filming the journey the point of the
voyage is to raise awareness around the
growing problem of plastic pollution in
our oceans so we know about ocean facet
being a problem all over the world and I
mean we've spent the last eight years
out there actually studying it but what
we want to do with this particular
voyage is to think about the fact that
it's actually also going on back here in
our home waters and also where the
solutions begin which are generally on
land as we go we'll be collecting water
samples to measure for micro plastics
and other chemicals to help get a
clearer idea of a set of issues experts
are only just beginning to understand
when plastic enters the ocean it breaks
down through the action of waves or Sun
into smaller and smaller fragments and
those fragments never really go away and
those fragments can also act as like
little sponges that can have toxic that
are dear to them and then those toxins
can enter the enter the food chain as
well so there's there's sort of a whole
cocktail of effects from plastics in our
oceans our boat is the sea dragon a 72
foot yacht designed to handle the
roughest conditions some of the team are
experienced sailors but many are not I'm
worried about I've got a top book some
weird about getting on and off that
seasickness the weather being cold being
wet and then if it's sunny getting
sunburned you know quite a few
challenges probably one of the biggest
challenges skippering a boat like this
is first of all figuring out what the
different people's talents are and where
the skill sets are filling in those
voids but also managing things as simple
as seasickness and stuff like that and
making sure that people are safe that
they're being part of the program and
learning lots of stuff but when we also
go down in our numbers and people aren't
able to manage for the moment making
sure that everything is running as it
should just be aware
rough weather below deck preparations
continue the professional crew briefing
the guests crew on the essentials
staying safe in the kitchen and keeping
the toilets working just some of the
many challenges we'll face the reality
of life on board a boat is that there's
very little space so everybody gets one
small box to put all their possessions
and clothes in and sleeping is also very
cramped there are 14 bunks on board and
this is going to be my bed for the next
month our journey begins tomorrow
evening a group of very different women
hoping to make a difference Hannah
Thomas Peter sky news in blue